Oscar nominees are out and there's lots
of surprises and snubs to discuss and I
have two panelists here that are never
short on words or verbiage but to kick
off this segment I wouldn't love to ask
y'all just in one word what was your
initial reaction to the Oscar
nominations when you woke up this
morning Jacqueline I'm a little bit
schizophrenic I'll get to that later but
it was a little divided on what the
Academy was viewing as you know
noteworthy and not okay schizophrenic
she's going with the $10 words right off
the bat Scott your one word to describe
one word one word my friends excited
excited excited excited lots to talk
about lots of snobs lots of surprises
lots of worthy films we're gonna get to
it all right now let's talk about Best
Picture now Black Panther Bohemian
Rhapsody Green Book a star is born black
Klansmen the favorite romo and advice
how about black panther though I mean
being a comic book film coming in and
beating a huge movie like Avengers
infinity war why was Black Panther the
movie that got the nomination because so
many other comic book movies in the past
that got stuck that's a very good point
because maybe like Avengers which I
think it was such an anticipated film
but what Black Panther represents not
just the diversity but the gender
equality the movie is called Black
Panther but that movie is an ensemble
it's a great ensemble and it is a
trailblazer and a groundbreaker because
of those merits and that's why it
deserved to get nominated for Best
Picture I mean I think obviously all
those things are true but I don't think
that is really the recipe that got it I
really think again like Ryan Coogler and
then again everybody he enlisted to be a
part of making this film they understood
the mandate that this film and what they
did on screen and also what it
represented was going to be bigger than
that so the only job they had was to
make a really compelling tight story
that regardless of the fact that it's
Marvel that people would enjoy and I
think that's why I resonated it was a
movie that was able to you know
basically put like palace intrigue and
and weaving into parts of like the
social landscape where people are asking
more poignant and like pushing through
with other questions based on what they
saw on screen that's the reason why it
works the actual nominations Jack when
you look at the eight out of a possible
10 that we got what was the biggest
prai's to you I mean I think the big
surprise I would say is actually the one
that was not on the list that's a Beale
Street could talk but that's another top
her another day a fair point tonight we
couldn't like break that one down but
honestly I would say vice because this
was a divisive film to kind of you know
borrow a little bit into that I mean
that's why it's 64% our tomato meter
didn't necessarily resonate that well
with critics didn't get a lot of love in
the critical circles la Film Critics New
York Film Critics the big groups kind of
besides the broadcast Film Critics they
gave it to Christian Bale voice kind of
kind of yeah twice exactly um what I
think is what it deserves but a Best
Picture I just didn't feel right now
Bohemian Rhapsody is one of the lowest
rated movies to be nominated
according to tomato meter since late
misra back in 2012 when this was 69%
Bohemian Rhapsody right now 60 to 2% and
then you also have Vice that is bringing
down the overall tomato meter so the
average score for Best Picture of the
2018 nominees for the 2019 ceremony is
eighty four point nine percent on the
tomato meter that may sound good it's a
solid B average it'll get you in a lot
of colleges however last year it was
ninety two point three percent in the
year before it was ninety two point four
percent there always if you would
average amount 90s because again
critical consensus and you can say what
you want to about my opinion about both
vice and Bohemian Rhapsody a vocal
minority disapproved of both of those
well how about this I can give you all
the critics consensus for Bohemian
Rhapsody too they say Bohemian Rhapsody
hits a handful of high notes but as an
in-depth look at a beloved ban it offers
more of a medley than a true greatest
hits collection and Scott I know that
you were surprised maybe a little
shocked at some people that did not get
nominated for Best Director
well the directing category was huge
this year because of who did not get
nominated I mean I definitely felt like
Peter Farrelly's should have been
nominated for Green Book he did get at
the retros guild nomination the movie
won Best Picture The Producers Guild
Awards
but the biggest up here clearly is
Bradley Cooper for a star is born this
movie peaked very early in the season
like right at the trifecta of film
festivals of Venice and then
Toronto and the problem is is that you
cannot be a front-runner and stay in
frontrunner for six straight months
going up against we are not gonna argue
the merits of the stars born with one
thing I will say about this is the fact
that I don't think it was because it
came too early I think it didn't
generate enough buzz to keep it going
because other films came up at that time
greenbook Roma
if Beale Street say what you want about
those films at least their conversations
didn't slow down is because Bradley
Cooper is a first-time director and is a
movie star and so we figure we can
nominate his movie for Best Picture we
don't have to worry about the director I
think they fell in love with some of the
more art or once again one of the if
you're gonna say one that took its lot
it's probable but also you're talking
about a movie that has now been done
four times yeah it's not an original
film it's a third remake you know you
can look in 1937 1954 1976 and guess mr.
movie release dates 2018 if the movies
been done that many times no matter how
great it is he directed the hell out of
it it is a very very good movie it is
solid in every vert and every respect
but it's not original it's not a
trailblazing unique film like Rowling
also gave a shout out to Roma simply
because they got nominated for Best
Picture and it was the first Netflix
film to do so and when we look at the
other surprises maybe some snubs that we
feel in some of the other major
categories Jacqueline I know you have a
Netflix movie on your mind what
surprised you this year yeah give it up
for Netflix because they got three
nominations off of the ballot of buster
shrugs and nobody had that movie on
their list yeah definitely not for
adapted certainly I mean maybe for Best
Song which is one of the nominations
that they got but definitely not for the
best costumes was the other one like
nobody had that on their list but for
Roma Wow
ten nominations for Roma so not only is
it the first streaming movie to get
nominated for Best Picture it's gonna be
the first streaming movie to win one
that I do think was an actual snub as
Barry Jenkins birth Beale Street katana
it only ended up with three nominations
total for the film and in a world where
the Vice and a Bohemian Rhapsody could
somehow outshine a film like that it
just goes to show you that this was not
about in my opinion the quality it was
just people voting for what they liked
and there's no female directors that
were nominated of the five and I think I
think one of the bigger snubs would be
Lynn Ramsay yeah and you could pair that
with even Joaquin Phoenix maybe
consideration for Best Performance er
Debra Granik also like Chloe Chou there
was a ton of female filmmakers making
extreme
moving heartfelt Oscar caliber movies
that did not really get any attention
from the Academy besides can you ever
forgive me
which obviously Marilyn Heller did that
one and the screenplay got you know one
of our two female women
yeah but not director any other big
snobs for y'all before we say goodbye
here it is it's a player for Emily Blunt
justice for Ethan Hawke and Toni
Collette that's the only things I have
to sign up well that's a great call
Terry hereditary Toni Collette and also
Ethan Hawke two films also both by a
twenty four so I have to shout out a
twenty four unfortunately yeah only had
Paul Schrader for first reform first
reform screenplay is the only thing they
got yeah those two performances the fact
that they could not be recognized by the
Academy in a year that granted had a ton
of stellar performances is just beyond
me well for me it's Emily Blunt not just
because she was nominated for lead
actress at the SAG Awards for Mary
Poppins returns and Supporting Actress
at the SAG Awards for a quiet place but
great year for Emily Blunt my plays
premiered at South by Southwest in March
had opened the beginning of April big
hit it's an original film she is superb
in that movie and then Merritt Paulson
returns the range that she displayed in
this year but also Claire Foy also I
thought overlooked for first man and
Nicole Kidman overlooked for supporting
for boy grace overlooked for lead for
the story and my biggest surprise won't
you be my neighbor did not get nominated
for Best Documentary hey mr. Rogers if
you wanted to get nominated maybe you
should have climbed El Capitan and with
that we're gonna say thank you and
goodbye for now but make sure you guys
subscribe right here to this youtube
channel and go to rottentomatoes.com for
all the latest nomination and award
coverage and comment below what was the
biggest snubber surprise in your opinion
we want to hear from you we'll see you
guys real soon
you